>> ALL RIGHT.
GREAT TO HAVE YOUR INSIGHTS ON
THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET THE VIEW FROM INSIDE
CONGRESS FROM SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
TARGETED.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
MY APOLOGIES THIS IS WHAT WE'LL
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAN THE
OTHER VARIOUS ISSUES THAT THE
VOTERS ARE LOOKING AT HEADING
INTO THE ELECTION.
AS YOU KNOW, AND OUR VIEWERS MAY
NO, A PENNSYLVANIA MAN PLEADED
GUILTY TO ONE COUNT AFTER THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THREATENED TO KILL THREE
STAFFERS AND BEAT THE S-H-I-T
OUT OF CONGRESSMAN.
HE HAD SEVERAL AR 15s.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THIS
PLEA AND THIS OVERALL THREAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT JUST SEEMS OUT
OF CONTROL RIGHT NOW?
>> THANKS, JIM.
THIS IS ONE OF MANY THREATS.
YOU REACHED OUT TO ME TO ASK
WHICH THREAT THIS WAS.
FRANKLY, I TOLD YOU I WAS GOING
TO HAVE TO LOOK IT UP BECAUSE WE
GET DOZENS OF VOICE MAIL THREAT,
THREATENING TO KILL ME, MY
FAMILY OR MY STAFF EACH WEEK.
WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT A PLEA,
THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S A DROP IN THE BUCKET FOR
WHAT'S OUT THERE.
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE FBI, DOJ AND
THE YONKERS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE SEEING POLITICAL RHETORIC
IS ON THE RISE AND WE'RE A
COUNTRY OF UNRESTRICTED
WEAPONRY.
THAT MAKES THIS SO VOLATILE AND
COMBUSTIBLE.
WHAT FRUSTRATES ME IS LEADERSHIP
HAS, LACK OF LEADERSHIP HAS
CONSEQUENCES AND INACTION HAS
CONSEQUENCES.
WHEN I SEE MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES FAIL TO CONDEMN THE
POLITICAL VIOLENCE THAT'S OUT
THERE OR IN MANY WAYS LIKE
MARJORY TAYLOR GREENE, IT GIVES
A GREEN LIGHT THAT IT'S OKAY TO
DO THIS.
>> WHAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT THAT?
>> FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT THESE
CRITICAL VOTER INTEGRITY SITES.
MAKE SURE BALLOT BOX DROP OFF
SITES ARE PROTECTED.
MAKE SURE THAT POLL WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PROTECT
THE STAFF AND OUR LAWMAKERS.
WE TRY TO EXTEND AND INCREASE
FUNDING FOR CAPITOL POLICE.
WE PASSED IT IN THE HOUSE.
THE SENATE DID NOT PASS IT.
IT WAS POLITICIZED.
WE HAVE TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE
INTELLIGENCE SIDE.
>> IT'S HAPPENING WAY TOO MUCH.
LET'S PLAY AUDIO OF WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
>> YOU'RE THE ENEMIES OF THE
UNITED STATES PEOPLE.
[ BLEEP ] YOU COMMUNIST ARE THE
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY,
CONSTITUTION AND THE WAY OF
LIFE.
I HOPE THAT CHOP YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY UP AND FEED THEM TO THEIR
DOGS YOU PIG.
YOU [ BLEEP ].
THERE'S YOUR FREE SPEECH FOR
TODAY.
TRUMP NATION.
WRITE IT DOWN YOU LITTLE
[ BLEEP ] TRUMP NATION, BABY.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU AND OTHERS
GET THESE VIOLENT, EVIL VOICE
MAILS AND YET YOU KEEP DOING THE
WORK THAT YOU DO.
I HAVE TO WONDER WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT YOU HAVE TO DISSECT
THAT, THEY'RE REFERRING TO YOU
AS ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE RHETORIC THAT IS
USED BY PEOPLE LIKE TRUMP,
MARJORY TAYLOR GREENE AND THE
OTHERS AND THESE THREATS THAT
ARE COMING INTO YOUR VOICE MAIL,
THE VOICE MAILS OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES?
>> THERE'S A STRAIGHT LINE FROM
WHAT DONALD TRUMP, MARJORY
TAYLOR GREENE, LAUREN BOBERT SAY
AND WHAT WE FIND ON THE
FACEBOOK, TWITTER FEED.
IF YOU DON'T WORK IN POLITICS,
YOUR FEED HAS YOUR FAMILY,
CHILDREN, HUNTING, YOUR PETS.
FOR THESE PEOPLE MAKING THREATS,
THEIR FACEBOOK PAGES LOOK
EXACTLY LIKE MARJORY TAYLOR
GREENE'S FACEBOOK PAGE AND
DONALD TRUMP FACEBOOK PAGE.
THEY ADOPT WHAT THEY HEAR FROM
LEADERS IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND BECAUSE IT'S NOT CONDEMNED
BY OTHER LEADERS LIKE KEVIN
McCARTHY, THEY GO OUT AND CARRY
OUT THE RHETORIC IN A VIOLENT
WAY THAT THEY ARE HEARING.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE ONLY ANTEDOTE IS UNITY
BETWEEN THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
WHEN WE DECIDE WHICH SIDE WINS
IN AMERICA, IT'S NOT BY A
BAYONET, IT'S AT THE BALLOT BOX.
>> YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE,
ADAM KINSINGER, HE WAS TOLD GET
IN LINE.
AS YOU KNOW, THE PROTECTION
DOESN'T COVER THE FAMILY WHEN
THE LAWMAKERS NOT WITH THEM.
WHAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT THAT?
>> YEAH.
WE NEED MORE RESOURCES TO
PROTECT FAMILY MEMBERS.
ALSO, IT'S NOT JUST THE FAMILY
MEMBER WHO IS ARE ON THE AX OR
THE STAFFER WORK ON THE X.
THE MEMBERS ARE TRAVELING IN
THEIR DISTRICT, CAMPAIGN STOPS,
OVERSEAS ON CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION TRIPS.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
STATIONARY.
THE STAFF MEMBERS WORK AT THE
CAPITOL.
THEY ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE
VICTIMS OF ONE OF THESE THREATS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING AND
THE RESOURCES RIGHT NOW.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BLOCKED OUR
EFFORTS TO PROTECT FAMILY
MEMBERS.
I SHARE THE FRUSTRATION THAT
ADAM HAS.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THE SAME
THING.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE YOU HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF THREATS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
PROTECT YOU.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE LAST
TWO DAYS WHO HAVE TEXTED ME
DIFFERENT FIREARMS THAT I SHOULD
BUY TO PROTECT MY FAMILY THAT'S
DISTURBING.
THAT'S A DETERRENT FOR PEOPLE
WANTING TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE THAT YOU HAVE TO ARM
YOURSELF TO THE TEETH OR HIRE
PUBLIC SECURITY.
MY CHIEF OF STAFF SAYS SHE SPENT
TEN HOURS EVERY WEEK JUST
DEALING WITH THE FBI AND THE
CAPITOL POLICE ABOUT THE THREATS
COMING INTO OUR OFFICE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO END UNTIL YOU
SEE REPUBLICAN LEADERS SAY
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERN THAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
CAN'T GET ENOUGH PROTECTION FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THAT THEY HAVE HAVING TO HIRE
PRIVATE SECURITY.
THAT'S HAPPENING --
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IS WHAT WE HAD TO SPEND
OUT OF OUR CAMPAIGN FUND BECAUSE
THE HOUSE WON'T COVER SECURITY
COSTS.
AGAIN, YOUR SUPPORTERS ARE
SUPPORTING YOUR EFFORT TO WIN
YOUR OWN ELECTION OR HELP OTHERS
WIN ELECTIONS AND INSTEAD YOU'RE
HAVING TO DIP INTO THAT BECAUSE
THE HOUSE WON'T PAY FOR PERSONAL
SECURITY.
AGAIN, IT'S ALMOST AS IF YOU CAN
THREATEN SOMEBODY AND FOR THEM
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES, IT
REDUCES THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
THEIR CASE FOR THEIR OWN
RE-ELE